hey guys it's Justine I'm here with Sam
and today we are glamping in are we in
Joshua Tree I think we're in Joshua Tree
we're in Joshua Tree
we're so excited because we're
celebrating Valentine's Day and we
thought what is a cool thing that you
could do on Valentine's Day you can go
glamping in Joshua Tree and make a cake
that's what what kind of cake are we
making so I got some things so we're
gonna make a heart cake and I brought
this this is a table for our wonderful
setup here
this is our campsite this is how you do
luxury glamping in Los Angeles we're at
Joshua Tree Joshua Tree so this is our
table yeah this is our tables okay okay
and we're just gonna make do with what
we have here that's what you do when you
were younger wilderness wonderful
careful I don't want you to get hurt
yeah nice no let me go get one there
might be bears I'm gonna I'm gonna get
started on this so as you can see we
have our fancy table legs and our even
fancier table table out here in the
wilderness
I love the wilderness and Joshua Tree
there might be bears I did not sign up
for this I don't think anybody signs up
for it we got to cut this off Justine
it's kind of deceiving working oh it's
gonna be on the u2 album no what's up
Wow okay send a throwback to the iPod
then you two like honey gosh is that a
Valentine's Day
I certainly do I don't know if it covers
daggers to the eye though so I do want
to mention that this is everything that
we have here I bought on Amazon Prime
now like 10 minutes before this 20
minutes ago are we missing something
I love glamping this is cool have you
baked a cake outside before how we're
gonna do this we're gonna make a fire
out here in Joshua tree out here in
Joshua Tree probably I don't think
they're allowed to sing about this is
gonna melt this is not gonna work at all
absolutely well enjoy the video while
you have it how big of a fire are we
talking well like I mean I haven't
thought about it yet okay yeah yeah okay
what's the problem I don't know it
design in the middle of nowhere are bird
sounds like we're being invaded by a by
a toy okay okay so really hope that this
doesn't fall I don't know what these are
for maybe to connect two of them I think
we don't need that ultimately you're
shutting away oh my god please watch
those fingers now I think we actually
like bake this cake we're still in
Joshua Tree um definitely not work we're
in Joshua Tree this is great place
working so well
have you made a cake before yeah I've
made brownies
oh um all brownies are special yeah
that's what I mean like with a specialty
is super special brownies yeah we're
making a strawberry premium naturally an
artificially flavored part cake I love
camping this is so fun yeah I go
glamping probably like once a week now
here in da schewe tree yep the weather
is I can't say I baked a heart-shaped
cake on my glamping excursions but you
know I haven't either
would you like to crack the eggs I don't
want to mess that up
I've had bad luck with egg cracking in
my day to be quite honest it's I'm
making a mess I don't I don't want to
jeopardize the integrity of said cake
this smells incredible oh my god wow the
temptation suggest that would probably
be that'll make this sick Wow I forgot
you can do that okay challenge go grab
it three more of those daggers and
juggle those
i okay so I ordered nine I'm so
impressive to juggle my mom made me
return them on Amazon because she was
here in town she's like you know okay
yeah I heard you need a task okay one we
need a cup of water okay I can make that
happen
oh wow thank you for the water one cup
of water
yeah okay there might be enough there if
not we'll just you know well you all
were in the desert
yeah the lack of water in there okay
yeah there's no order of operations I
mean probably but clearly that doesn't
matter
I have you baked a cake before oh yes I
baked many I don't care so we're in good
hands here we also need a half cup of
oil okay I love bringing oil to the
desert place the camp at here obviously
the wilderness wait you said half a cup
or a full cup half cup
coming right up yes here we go oh my god
it smells so good
so normally I would probably use like a
stand mixer we're in the right there's
no out here mix until moistened beat
with mixer on medium for two minutes
you've got it going here bake at 350 how
long
well pan size six inches across maybe
hopefully eight inches I don't know
anywhere in the vicinity of 25 minutes
to 30 minutes that's a long time yeah I
know we're gonna have to get this fire
going oh I have matches so we can we can
start there if desired sub two four egg
whites here okay we're not gonna
substitute because we always no no no no
so the one thing that is extremely
important when you're making is hey
Tyler can you throw me that spray you
know that's okay that's fine that's
really not important we're in the desert
there's no one else here and if so death
let in remote you want to always spray
the pan yeah so it doesn't get stuck yes
this is probably also very
flammable can I do something really
stupid yeah go ahead do it I know what
you're gonna do I love it Wow Wow whoa
should I go get the fire extinguisher
now uh yeah we should have that on
daytime sure definitely you know it's
funny I've actually never done that in
my whole life
today's the day that was today I feel
very accomplished I'm glad I came all
the way out here to Joshua Tree where do
not try that at home kids yeah and
especially not in the desert of Joshua
Tree either no way never dry here have
you ever used one of these before I have
actually I have they make a mess an
absolute mess if you don't know it kind
of shoots out like this misty fine
powder
that's a boom right Docs yeah don't do
that unless you're really putting out a
fire I used one in my last place that I
lived why I don't live in the other
place anymore
do I pour it with this little lip this
is a lovely Rosanna pansino whoa how
high do I go probably not too high like
that's good I think yeah will it rise it
will rise a little have you ever used
these heart-shaped pans before I have
yes
got to get some logs okay wait let me
get let me guess you're gonna bring your
finger get this along whoops that's not
gonna work we need a bigger flame do we
have something that can bake this all
right so let's see this just like
cooking it on a stove I don't know if
this is gonna work it also might melt
this little contraption let's elevate
this a little bit we can properly cook
it and try again I'll do two matches
this time maybe that will set things up
better for me I'm definitely definitely
heating it up I think this might be
working I don't think that's working oh
dear I don't think are you gonna are you
gonna oh god
all right let's make this half let's
let's make mommy's cake tonight you
should not be Stannis is gonna are you
gonna pull the trigger this actually
might work no what you don't think it's
gonna work fire is baking oh my god it's
done
it's like the cake is done Wow well that
actually kind of maybe worked a little
bit no that didn't maybe work that
freakin work Wow we let it sit maybe we
let it sit a little bit okay that like
really worked fast and I was maybe 30
seconds of it was incredible Wow screw
using an oven
there's no point especially in the
wilderness
well you Joshua Tree yeah Wow nothing
went wrong like we we started with not a
cake and we have a cake we haven't used
yeah Wow look at this should we cut into
ever seen something so beautiful under
ours day I think I understand I got to
make sure
[Music]
proceed with caution
percebes question also so I shouldn't
grab this and move it it's not really
not but I can because I've got these
mixed is it gonna flip no way
well we dressed it up let's see well I'm
more afraid of this panic oh my Wow gosh
Wow
I'm correct me if I'm wrong what does
that not look like grilled cheese we
shouldn't eat it though don't done yet
we shouldn't yeah we decorated yes yes
yes have you decorated no I have not
these are also from rose baking Oh this
is how you make it all pretty so I think
the middle maybe a little
well flavorful too little mushy not
quite good thoroughly there's too hard
because oh boy I think the center may
still be a little a little gooey do we
take the flame to it again we can man
camping is fun
mm-hm I agree surprisingly I love icing
cakes so much why is that surprising in
the slightest I don't know it's like
building like a Lego set or something oh
you like are you like it and making it I
like like icing it okay like icing yeah
it's fine it's looking like a it's
getting a pancake you happened I don't
know this to me all I see is like melted
mozzarella cheese so this is not your
first rodeo the first cake I've made
using a flame thrower watches through
network wants
grabs the flame thrower now you're much
better at this time and then we get to
do the sprinkles not perfect but you
know what we're in the desert and it's
hot and the icing is melted iJustine
youtuber cake baker extraordinaire
goodness looks really good
no one can even believe that this is
the flamethrower good luck you two I'll
try not not to eat these along the way
they're well they're edible come to a
degree yeah this is pretty good actually
really good okay all right okay now
there's one thing left to do we have to
cut the king we have to cut the cake and
taste it
okay different one this one okay Oh yep
and you're touching it very what I just
wanted to make sure all right comes
right down the middle it still looks
pretty good like I'm impressed
is it cooked in the middle what do you
think uh I think so
like I said grilled cheese with pink
cheese Wow imagine that we just
accidentally made a meme pink cheese
20:19 well haven't you seen the rainbow
girl cheese's before no like two years
ago I've seen rainbow bagels from like
cheese I made green shamrock oh wait you
remember to remember the green ketchup
Heinz ketchup do and they did oh yeah
yeah try it it's a question I think so
okay we might as well alright just to
satisfy the viewer my knife down okay
okay I want to take like a little edge
where it's like actually Cup yeah okay
so I'm just going this okay okay oh it
smells really bad yeah we smell the char
oh okay mmm Cheers bottoms up yummy
[Music]
hmm tastes like strawberries I mean
actually really good mmm nice and gooey
enjoyed it I mean we definitely I mean
there's salt like the edges are baked I
think we can say with confidence we
baked a cake we baked a cake in Joshua
Tree on Valentine's Day Valentine's Day
with a flame thrower disguised a roofing
torch disguise in the flamethrower yeah
don't actually ever eat this nope yeah
we record we baked a second cake in
Justine's kitchen that is right there
that is that is the power of doing
things that are edited and not live
Internet is an entire lie but what is
not a lie is we actually did bake this
with a flamethrower though that is true
this is really good this is incredible a
boxed strawberry cake pretty good pretty
good
this is still the batter that we cook
though out here correct well it's not
entirely look alive
yeah we're also not in Joshua Tree oh no
way
yeah I know right what do you say cool
well guys thanks for watching go check
out savings channel I'll put all of his
links below in the description go say hi
we're gonna eat the rest of this cake
mm-hmm and you know the last time
somebody ate a cake I baked I got food
poisoning it's probably actually you
should probably step up well happy
Valentine's Day from a man just steamed
in Joshua Tree to you guys okay just
keep eating you're gonna poop yourself
movie yep because of the food poisoning
because
Oh
[Music]